aproximadamente una vez al mes se
desarrolla una serie de eventos
denominada ciclo menstrual para preparar
el cuerpo de una mujer para el embarazo
niveles cambiantes de sustancias
químicas naturales en el torrente
sanguíneo denominadas hormonas controlan
estos eventos los órganos reproductores
afectados por estas hormonas incluyen la
vagina
el cuello uterino
el útero
las trompas de falopio
y los ovarios
los ovarios producen dos hormonas
principales denominadas estrógeno y
progesterona
a medida que el nivel de estrógeno
empieza a aumentar la mucosidad espesa
normal del cuello uterino adelgaza
el estrógeno también activa a otras
hormonas para que uno de los ovarios
libere un óvulo este proceso se denomina
ovulación
si una mujer mantiene relaciones
sexuales durante este periodo las
células reproductivas masculinas
denominadas espermatozoides pueden pasar
a través de la mucosidad más delgada
para fertilizar un óvulo
en el útero el estrógeno engrosa el
endometrio y lo prepara para recibir un
óvulo fertilizado
el aumento de los niveles de
progesterona provoca que las glándulas
de la pared liberen un líquido que
alimenta el óvulo fertilizado
también hace que la mucosidad adelgazada
del cuello uterino se vuelva a espesar
lo que evita el paso de los
espermatozoides
si no se fertilizó un óvulo los niveles
de estrógeno y de progesterona empiezan
a disminuir
esta disminución en los niveles
hormonales provoca la menstruación un
proceso en el cual el útero elimina el
revestimiento de tejido interno y la
sangre a través de la vagina
las píldoras anticonceptivas son
medicamentos que una mujer toma a diario
para evitar quedar embarazada
la píldora combinada es el método de
control de natalidad más frecuente y
eficaz contiene tanto estrógeno como
progestina que es una hormona producida
por el hombre similar a la progesterona
el estrógeno y la progesterona mantienen
constantes los niveles de estas hormonas
en el cuerpo
estos niveles evitan que el cuerpo
libere hormonas similares que provocan
la ovulación sin la ovulación no hay un
óvulo disponible para su fertilización y
por lo tanto una mujer no puede quedar
embarazada
la progestina también evita el embarazo
ya que mantiene la mucosidad del cuello
uterino lo suficientemente espesa como
para que los espermatozoides no puedan
pasar por él un tercer efecto de la
progestina en el embarazo es su
influencia en la pared del útero
a diferencia de la progesterona natural
la progestina difiere un poco
químicamente con el tiempo hace que el
endometrio sea más delgado en lugar de
más grueso
como resultado si se fertiliza un óvulo
la pared puede ser demasiado delgada
como para que éste pueda permanecer en
el útero de manera que sale del cuerpo
en el siguiente periodo menstrual
en general las píldoras combinadas
vienen en envases de 28 días según la
marca de la píldora las primeras 21 a 24
píldoras son activas ya que contienen
hormonas las últimas 4 a 7 píldoras son
inactivas o píldoras recordatorias que
no tienen hormonas las píldoras
inactivas permiten que los niveles
hormonales del cuerpo disminuyan para
que se pueda producir el sangrado
durante el ciclo menstrual
aunque las píldoras inactivas no
contienen hormonas
la mujer permanece protegida contra un
embarazo durante este periodo las
píldoras inactivas también se denominan
píldoras recordatorias porque ayudan a
la mujer a mantener el hábito de tomar
una píldora anticonceptiva a diario
existen otras píldoras que sólo
contienen progestina también llamadas
mini píldoras al igual que la píldora
combinada la progestina en las píldoras
que sólo contienen progestina evitan el
embarazo al impedir la ovulación
y provocar el engrosamiento de la
mucosidad cervical
y el adelgazamiento de la pared del
útero
las mujeres pueden elegir píldoras que
sólo contienen progestina si no toleran
el estrógeno de las píldoras combinadas
debido a efectos secundarios u otros
motivos médicos las píldoras que sólo
contienen progestina son activas
el sangrado menstrual con las píldoras
que sólo contienen progestina puede
producirse una vez al mes
esporádicamente durante el mes o es
posible que no se produzca sangrado
para una máxima protección contra
embarazos es importante tomar las
píldoras que sólo contienen progestina a
la misma hora todos los días
tanto las píldoras combinadas como las
píldoras que sólo contienen progestina
tienen una eficacia de un 99 por ciento
en la prevención de embarazos que se
utilizan correctamente esto implica que
aproximadamente una de cada 100 mujeres
quedará embarazada cada año si no las
utiliza de manera correcta
sin embargo tienen una eficacia de
alrededor de un 92 por ciento si se
utilizan de forma habitual lo que
significa que aproximadamente 8 de cada
100 mujeres quedarán embarazadas cada
año si no recuerdan tomarlas todos los
días